hey what's going on as bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday June 13 2016 what's going on
how the [ __ ] are you I'm hanging out
here Sunday night there's thirty point
two seconds left in Game six and barring
a little out there on the ice worthy of
a Lake Placid sequel I'm going to go out
on a limb and say that the [ __ ]
Pittsburgh Penguins are going to win
their fifth cup just a fifth one that's
[ __ ] right so successful that is
they've only been around since 67 the
Bruins been around forever we only got
six you [ __ ] congratulations to
the Pittsburgh Penguins man that's
[ __ ] great and uh really happy for
Phil Kessel this is actually a good one
for me as a Bruins fan because Joe
Thornton was uh you know another form of
Bruin so either way I was gonna say and
I'd like both those [ __ ] players you
know I mean because of for the Phil
Kessel trade to Toronto we want a cup
granted we then traded everybody the
[ __ ] away but we did win a cup you know
so I can't say some [ __ ] to [ __ ] in
Montreal fans finally twenty seconds to
go nineteen I'll tell you this is a
choppy stroke be aware no [ __ ] goes
you're in professional sports there's
got to be one of the most how the [ __ ]
was that icing the goalie played it ah
Jesus Christ what is this the [ __ ]
NBA by the way I kinda I guess I
understand now why it's not as physical
in the NBA I actually looked up some of
the rules the obviously the three-second
rule isn't even is like an offensive
player are you allowed to be I don't
know one of these guys can go down the
[ __ ] lane a defensive player can't be
in the [ __ ] painted area for longer
than three seconds or it's an illegal
defense he is allowed to stand there if
he's within arm's length of the guy that
he's guarding so all the guys got to do
is just [ __ ] run out to the
three-point land and they just clear it
clear the path right and it comes the
honor roll student right down the [ __ ]
leg like jack-ay his quickness yeah he
has his
our step yeah and the fact that there's
now a [ __ ] rule that says you can't
have some giant [ __ ] guy standing
there oh look it up going crazy Wow
another one in the books you know
something I'm not claustrophobic but one
of the worst things you want to be after
winning a championship is that person on
the bottom of the [ __ ] pile you know
you literally go from like celebrating
that you want to not even being able to
breathe you like yeah you get tackle you
just like that [ __ ] do you know that
there's been times people who scored big
[ __ ] touchdowns and they get tackled
by the teammates a kid like their
[ __ ] leg broken it's unbelievable
anyways congratulations to the
Pittsburgh Penguins uh and Pittsburgh
great great [ __ ] hockey town I know
we've had our rivalry in that thing but
I've just been that too many times I got
too many friends there and uh
congratulations to Joe bartnik he's got
to be going [ __ ] crazy right now if I
didn't have [ __ ] to do tomorrow I would
have gone over his place and watch the
game San Jose Sharks tell man you know
he never made it to a final so you got
over the hump and I can have that bitter
taste in your mouth and hopefully you'll
come back and win one unless my [ __ ]
Bruins get their [ __ ] together and then
we [ __ ] finally win one so anyways
let's get on with the podcast here I had
a yeah had my birthday weekend wonderful
birthday weekend old Billy booze bag was
[ __ ] throwing him down Oh Billy booze
bag was act in a clamp right and [ __ ]
Joey roses was over right came over all
my birthday to my house when I say Joey
you say Rosie he came over [ __ ] guy
was hilarious he came over with like a
bottle of gin something some a [ __ ]
lemon and then he had those those
[ __ ] red cherries that might or might
not cause cancer to Phil Kessel looks
like he [ __ ] will he's like works
with wood doesn't he like some weird guy
that never married but he could [ __ ]
you know make a Davenport out of the
[ __ ] tree stuff you can take phil
kessel though how's your breath pretty
bad eh
oh the wonderful tradition of the NHL is
shaking over has the show of mutual
respect roughly an hour anyways uh yeah
so I [ __ ] went I went way too hard on
my birthday you know because I didn't
think and you know I didn't really do
anything I worked all [ __ ] day and
then I came home I had a Coors Light and
I was just like you know what it's my
birthday I'll [ __ ] have a scotch right
hook up my big giant [ __ ] cube of ice
and I threw out two scotches and next
thing you know [ __ ] roses was coming
over and I already had three in the
[ __ ] three in the wind column so I
don't really remember most probably the
third last third of the [ __ ] night
and all I know is I got a bunch of dirty
looks for my wife the next day so last
night I went out again and I only had
like a couple of beers and then that's
it that's it I'm shutting it down again
that's how I stay in control you know
the thing about you livers you don't
want to spoil it
you know I've slapped it around enough
so now I give it a break and then just
when it starts to think hey you know
what everything is beautiful I give it
the old [ __ ] right there Fred that's
what I do I had a it was actually great
weekend I didn't do any stand-up he that
I got to get my [ __ ] [ __ ] together
some of you doing a couple shows this
week around LA because I got a I got
Newark Atlantic City in Baltimore coming
up this weekend so I can make sure the
act is ready to go nice and [ __ ]
tight there and but this weekend you
know obviously celebrated my birthday
Friday night and let's see what did I do
say I went to somebody else's [ __ ]
birthday party so uh and that one that
was the one that I actually didn't
really drink at but I still felt
horrible because at one point I had a
tequila
and after that I had birthday cake and
then I smoked a cigar and then my body
was just like all right can we can we
[ __ ] pick a road here which which
which way is the abuse going tonight you
know but I was so hungover Saturday I
couldn't even [ __ ] walk the ten feet
to my gym house that's when I know is
that guy - yeah you what are you doing
so I shut it down it's over put a
padlock on it I don't know how long I'm
going to go I know you know what it is
this is actually once the [ __ ]
playoffs are over it's kind of easy but
I'm also going to be starting peaky
blinders so that might be hard where
those [ __ ] guys drink I don't
understand how you watch a show
everybody's boozing and you don't
[ __ ] drink any alcoholic sout they're
like how the [ __ ] do you watch that
stuff and just be like Oh everybody else
is drinking I feel like I'm being rude
right now I'm thinking maybe I'm going
to shut it down till I go to Europe but
even then I can't really drink as I got
to show every [ __ ] night but I did
set myself up in in a hotel on one of
those dates that there's actually a
cigar bar right around the corner so I
might have my one for July I feel like
I'm just [ __ ] babbling this is just
me just trying to keep my bad habits at
bay this is the deal either I'm not
drinking at all I'm smoking too many
cigars or I cut down the cigars and I
drink like a [ __ ] lunatic you know
what I mean like I've said before I
literally think the reason why people
have kids is so they won't [ __ ] drink
themselves to death because once you
[ __ ] get yourself going in your
career and you got some free time why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you walk over
what are you going to [ __ ] do huh
after that [ __ ] horrible tragedy down
there in Orlando which I I will never
[ __ ] understand lunatic religious
people
I just never understand how you get so
[ __ ] up in your head that you feel
like that's your last act on earth okay
that's the last thing you're going to do
and you think that you're going to go
somewhere good that there's somebody
after this if there is somebody after
this that judged you that he's going to
be sick
they're going like all right way to go
there yeah that was the right thing to
do make millions of people sad you know
it's just it's still [ __ ] worst thing
ever
and I'm actually going to take a break
here from TV probably for other than
sports it's a great thing about sports
is you can get away from that stuff
because I can't handle when something
like this happens how quickly oh god is
he getting booed
is he getting booed you know it it's
plop acid every [ __ ] year this is the
funniest [ __ ] ever in hockey every
[ __ ] year
the Commissioner of the league comes out
and he just gets [ __ ] I don't know
why he's still getting booed let's see
this here hang on a second sleeve
summers wrote those words and now it's
engraved on the side of the Stanley Cup
I rub my balls on it right before it one
of the greatest trophies a nose for look
at Mario Lemieux looking sharp huh he's
got his anchorman sport coat on Tom Berg
Tom Berg and he [ __ ] the [ __ ] his
name oh here he comes
he's complimenting them is one of the
loudest buildings I've ever heard that
bowing him his children must cry every
[ __ ] year
so anyways back to the tragedy sorry I
can't handle whenever something like
that [ __ ] happens and then you got to
sit there and listen to all of these
[ __ ] people trying to shoehorn their
agendas in there they're you know the
[ __ ] theories and then somehow it
always becomes Democrat liberal [ __ ]
conservative Republican Muslim Christian
[ __ ] gun control an RA and all that
[ __ ] and you know it's [ __ ] it's so
stupid you know it's funny if you look
at the Daily News in New York City right
they're anti-gun but you know that's
what you want to be that's what you want
to be but if you anti-gun and you really
want you know that to work wouldn't you
you need what you need to do is persuade
the other side to come over there
headline is thanks a lot NRA or some
stupid [ __ ] like that all it does is
just get people's [ __ ] back up all
I'm saying it's just going to be a bunch
of people screaming and yelling right
it's going to be a couple of actors and
actresses that are going to say
something stupid right I don't know what
but you know we're always good to do
something like that people in the
[ __ ] people forget that they're a
dancing monkey and think that they could
solve the country's problems for the
[ __ ] life of me I mean I know I
[ __ ] talk about the ship but I never
try to offer solutions
you know maybe well my I tell dick and
[ __ ] jokes and [ __ ] strip malls but I
gotta tell you though I just wish people
out of respect for the amount of [ __ ]
paint that was just inflicted I can't
even imagine what that number fifty
people how many people right now are
just never going to be this
saying you would think that people could
go 24 [ __ ] hours without making it
about their cause and screaming and
yelling as much as they're trying to
[ __ ] help can you just tell us just
you know can you go 20 [ __ ] minutes
before we got to listen to people saying
that so bama's fault that [ __ ] this
and that everything you know what I
don't know whose fault it's nobody's
fault you know what it is dude
unfortunately we're [ __ ] we're
animals that's what it is most of us are
decent enough not to do that but it's
just what are you going to do just
[ __ ] horrible why would I talk about
this [ __ ] you know why because it's
because well how do you not how do you
not mom anyways so Sidney Crosby got the
MVP get that little shiny house with the
[ __ ] I don't know disco hat on top of
it alright when's he given it to phil
kessel
when's he giving it to phil kessel who's
he handed off to first who's he handed
off to first one of the great traditions
of all sports that's a ways [ __ ] 9000
pubs until you put it over your head
then it feels like a baby you're worried
about dropping you hear all the stories
about the Stanley Cup all the [ __ ] I
can't believe they drink out of that
thing every year the amount of [ __ ]
stripper ass that has been sitting in
that thing people pissing in it and all
kinds of [ __ ] least it ends up at the
bottom of a pool couple times you get
some chlorine and I'm exposing myself to
the fact I don't know who anybody is on
the [ __ ] Penguins all right he
handled it he just added a cup to not
Phil Kessel
not Phil Kessel not Phil Kessel holding
it up holding it up turning spitting my
numbers he number six not Phil Kessel
Jesus Christ he should have [ __ ]
skated around a little more
daily do it I would [ __ ] take off
with that thing I swear to God if I ever
got to do that thing be like when
what's-his-face it's one of his [ __ ]
shots at the end of his practice
speaking of which Jesus Christ I was
hoping for at least at least a [ __ ]
six game series with the Cavaliers I may
guess that's not going
happen right anyways let's plow ahead
here with the podcast I'll stop watching
I got to keep this on until Elyse I'll
get to watch Phil Kessel always the
[ __ ] cup here huh
the woodworker here anyways you know
what I watch this sports this morning
is I watched the the Formula One race
the one up in Montreal kind of getting
into that sport you know does I never
know what to do when talking in
basketball ends you know what am I gonna
do read God knows I'm not going to funk
and do that right
I'm just filibustering taking his [ __ ]
already I don't know if he's been
waiting that long come on you gotta give
it to Phil he's [ __ ] adorable okay
here we go Phil Castle Phil castle nope
some assistant captain oh jesus that
smoke it I didn't recognize him with a
hat on
he's not one of those guys whose [ __ ]
mustache and beard doesn't connect you
know Jesus you've got a terrible patchy
[ __ ] I don't know what not what he's
got going on there that's really the
thing people can either you know I you
know it's the worse is the [ __ ]
neckbeard you know those people it
[ __ ] it starts off all right by the
ear and then it just [ __ ] goes
there's a nosedive you guys like the
chinstrap goes right up and under and
they got like five hairs on their upper
lip and you just like what are you doing
you know the Tang has it now and I just
have to be excruciatingly boring I'm
gonna hit pause here until phil kessel
gets it and of course they cut it off
before he's [ __ ] hoisted thing
because they had a cut immediately to a
get you championship t-shirts and
[ __ ] hats all right I'll find a
[ __ ] clip of it alright with that I'm
gonna shut the TV off so I can actually
focus here yeah so shutting down the
booze but I can shut down the booze hit
my little [ __ ] gym out there you know
what I mean get myself a [ __ ] man
sports bra and [ __ ] get after it you
know not smoke cigars I'll be the most
in-shape and bored I've ever [ __ ]
been
I got to correct a couple of things from
the last podcast I did on Thursday John
Salley is not dead I meant to say
Anthony Mason I don't know I was half a
[ __ ] sleep all right
and so I want to thank all you [ __ ] on
Twitter to dead like you can just write
to me hey Bill John Salley isn't dead
you had to put at John Salley so he
could have potentially saw it why the
[ __ ] would you do that - you know why
because you're [ __ ] bored that's why
we're hoping something's [ __ ] Twitter
dust-up what happened I guess I
understand this whole [ __ ] generation
of Yolo douches they're all about
filming people get them in trouble
hashtag and [ __ ] adding people on stuff
just trying to constantly cause these
[ __ ] fights
it's unbelievable pant you just go
outside and pick up a stick and pick
cowboys-and-indians like we used to walk
around with your [ __ ] iPad and yeah
your GoPro all [ __ ]
I got a GoPro for my birthday I'm such a
hypocrite I wanted to get one of those
things and you know I'm I'm toying with
the idea doing that show the how long
can you go which is basically me pulling
out of the driveway in my house and then
you see how long I can go without
snapping on people but I just don't want
to make myself look like a [ __ ]
lunatic you know because I feel like
I've built up a great reputation for
being even keeled on this podcast all
right let's do it let's do a little
[ __ ] nom advertising Reed's here for
the week with an allowing alright right
here okay MVM tea watches everybody when
you're in your early 20s and 30s money
can be tight if you're not careful
dressing well can quickly drain your
bank account like spending 400 to 500
bucks on a department store watch
there's some brands out there charging
insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it well if you want to look
great when you go out but still have
enough money to buy him or her a drink
check out the movement him or her a
drink oh god this feminist agenda
consult is that happening
out there you're really going on a date
and she buys the [ __ ] drink is that
is that what's happening is that why
Bruce became Caitlyn he was so much of a
man he goes I'm out I'll buy it drinks
my whole life nobody's buying me a drink
I'm going to become a lady all right
check out movement watches comm I've
seen them before and these watches are
sharp why do they [ __ ] do that stop
saying that I've seen [ __ ] jesus [ __ ]
christ i [ __ ] hate when people do
that just just give me the spiel and
I'll read it stop saying that I did
things that I didn't do
clearly all right actually they did send
me some launches I'm sorry I'm VMT
you're right I did see them oh Jesus all
right originally founded by two broke
college kids movement watches cut out
the middle know if you were broke how
the [ __ ] did you start the company this
doesn't add up
all right movement watches cut out the
middleman and their big brand retail
markups in order to give you a stylish
watch for an affordable price movement
watch you start at just 95 bucks a watch
what department store quality for a
fraction of the price
there's sleek and minimalistic and a
modern twist on a classic style a modern
twist on a classic style movement has
grown organically purely by supporters
like you they started at a farmers
market right next week all organic corn
so join their more than 1 million social
media followers and get a movement watch
today today today go to mV mt Michael
Victor Michael Tom watches calm slash /
and they'll give you 15% off your entire
purchase
that's MV MT watches dot-com / / alright
blue apron everybody don't you wish you
knew how to cook but you didn't have to
shop and they just gave you all the
directions on how to do it well thank
God somebody does Oh blue apron blue
apron knows that when you cook with
incredible ingredients you make
incredible meals unless you [ __ ] it up
so they set the highest believe me I
bought some great cuts of meat in my
time and I Christ you cut the [ __ ] out
of it
so they sent the highest quality they
set the highest quality standards for
their community of our tensional
suppliers Jesus what's that some hipster
slaughtering a [ __ ] pig using some
tool we bought off eBay that some
[ __ ] made in 1870 family-run farms
fisheries and ranchers whether it's
Japanese ramen noodles wild caught
Alaskan salmon or heirloom tomatoes blue
apron is bringing you the best for less
than $10 per meal blue apron delivers
seasonal recipes along with
pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals additional
copy points featured as desired Oh does
that mean I don't have to read these
alright we'll do one of them easy each
meal comes with step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe card pre-portion
ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes it's flexible customers
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences and a new recipes
are created each week by blue apron sis
this is phenomenal I wish they had this
when I was younger check out this week's
menu and get two meals for free with
free shipping by going to blue apron com
/ / you will love how good it feels and
taste to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron so don't wait
that's blue apron calm / / blue apron a
better way to cook but that's a good way
to lose weight - all right hey maybe
I'll lay off the booze and start doing
blue apron no alright stamps.com
everybody mailing and shipping our
routine part of your business important
keeps your operations going i swear to
god that that was sort of a sentence
important keeps your operation going
dot dot dot hang on what's up Nia what
are we doing I want to be a taco man you
making tacos what are you making tacos
by me is it going to be anything special
come over here before you start yelling
I mean like when you're making the tacos
tonight you're going to add a little
little Nene in there you're just going
to [ __ ] do it by the box I'm doing it
by the box cuz
yeah I mean it's just tacos what do you
what would be different I don't know you
always open the fridge and you go oh you
know what I'll do that I didn't know we
had bacon I'll throw that in there
nah well you know what I there is a
little something different I take that
back I did throw something in there that
uh might be a little unexpected when we
returned one of my duds don't [ __ ]
talk to me like that no none of your
goddamn business 23 minutes
IG this bill so we're gonna go on for
another hour
well yeah that's what I do right now I'm
talking about stamps calm Oh
have you got that zip no I have it
they're not on today all right now
they're not I gotta finish this
all right well time it out why are you
gonna like like when you make them about
Fred Flintstone used to come home well
mom coming through the door and she had
to have the Bronto burger ready it's
ready right now what what are you
looking for what oh yeah my John Baker
what you know what kills me somebody
sent me a tweet and said that on the
Opie and Anthony show in 2005 11 years
ago they showed me that come up somebody
send me that too and they I had
absolutely no recollection of this how
would I forget that because it was 2005
a long time ago I know but this is like
that's that's I still remembered you
know we're late we're late charlie bit
my finger we're not late how did all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] look you just you
know like yeah I haven't had time to see
everything on the internet you [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's so stupid I love the more
I'm on this I like just talking into the
abyss I got to stop [ __ ] reading
Twitter
I [ __ ] hate people did to Twitter you
are truly addicted to Twitter no just my
phone I'm not doing that either I was
looking today I was looking at both
Formula One drivers I watched two
Formula One races in a row now I need to
know everything about the sport you're
so rain
like that though you like that's what
you like to do got to know everything
going to find out everything yeah I get
it all in there and then I forget it
then I move on to something else and
that's probably why I [ __ ] forgot
that that video yeah you know is a Red
Bull team in Formula One and I'm just
sitting I don't I didn't know that
because I've just seen people wearing
their jackets and jumpsuits and it's on
the side of cars how did you not see it
if I know this well I was thinking
mother's there was a Mercedes team and
then there was the Ferrari team and then
there was like Red Bull I'm like they're
a [ __ ] drink so I was like well who
made their engine who baby who made the
car and then they said it was they said
it was Tag Heuer Renault
it's like tag or is a [ __ ] watch well
when I type in who makes you [ __ ]
engines I don't want to hear about the
watch people maybe you should leave out
the [ __ ] part all right
Touche I didn't know that that's how you
get into Tag Heuer but no a Red Bull is
a huge brand so of course I sponsor
stuff like this no but they were saying
you know the Ferrari the Mercedes and
then they would never say what kind of
[ __ ] they never said the Renault
it's a French company making the [ __ ]
engine and I think it's a British team
and then they're talking about a [ __ ]
energy drink where the other guys got to
be like Mercedes Ferrari and you get to
be like yeah man of course those guys
are like they've been doing it forever
and all of a sudden redbull shows up the
Yolo douche is a [ __ ] Formula One and
they don't even tell me who makes their
engine I mean that used to be like a big
[ __ ] thing back in the day the reason
why you want it was you'e proven you're
the best car company and then
everybody's like well [ __ ] Ferrari won
the last five I'm going to buy a Ferrari
not everybody people could afford it I'm
still confused what's your problem with
Red Bull
I didn't I didn't like how I think I
want to know who's making that engine
that's winning the [ __ ] race not give
a [ __ ] about the drink okay
so your haven't been able to figure out
who makes the engine in this one
particular race car no I had to look it
up
this [ __ ] young punk kid was not
letting the guy won the first three or
four get past them to get into fourth
place and the guy got in patient and I
knew he was gonna because that's what I
would have done and I knew he was a
little bit older I'm like
he doesn't have time for this kid and he
[ __ ] tried to go around the right and
then he locked up the brakes he spun out
and he [ __ ] himself out of like two
spots on the last lap and everybody in
the crowd went oh it's exciting so at
the end of the day you got the
information that you wanted it was just
the fact that redbull in their Bay you
are annoyed but it's really hard to
follow you sometimes okay Mercedes is a
maker of cars yeah so when I know it's
the Mercedes team I know that the
engineers the mechanics would have [ __ ]
you call them that that's their car okay
when they talk about the Ferrari team I
know that that's their car I know who
built the [ __ ] thing when you say Red
Bull who build the Red Bull car it's
harder to figure out hey you want to use
oh my god
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
forgot are you know because I just
remind me how I always they just
reminded me of a drink what my dad
called Grey Goose one ton he goes hey
Bill he goes you still drinking that
blue Swan you know what and it just
occurred to me that's where you get it
from that's where you get all that stuff
the last days of Dracula to [ __ ] in a
pool you know that weird the [ __ ] go
like you get that from him like you guys
have a vague idea of what it is that
you're scoping off what I'm doing the
movie thing so you're just like throwing
out like signifiers like you know that
there's there's a girl and she's being
[ __ ] and there was a pool so yeah too
horrible
it's vampire and they're doing some sort
of an interview so yeah the last dates
are Dracula well I know I'm doing more
like the $10,000 pyramid like I'm
throwing out clues for the listener and
then they just go do you mean that I go
yeah I mean that because if I don't do
that I'm going to sit there going up and
I'm not going to remember and they're
they going to be tortured so it becomes
like a little game you know what I mean
I wonder how you would do on that
pyramid show because you know they're
bringing it back I would do horrible I
myself would just give if I was giving
you a clue
ever
right wouldn't you all right you know
what let's play right now I'm going to
get a [ __ ] word and we're going to
put we're going to play right now all
right we'll do the couple of these get
out of here get you got to get a
microphone go get a microphone we finish
reading this [ __ ] advertising yeah
Jesus Christ they started this like 20
minutes ago hey guys remember way back
in the day when I was talking about
stamps calm guess what they're still in
business yes yet dinner important keeps
your operations going I swear to god
that's still a sentence but if you're
making constant trips to the post office
that's a routine you need to change
there's a much more convenient way at
stamps calm stamps calm brings all of
the services of the post office right to
your desk by imprint official US postage
I just realized you guys need to know
what the [ __ ] words are so you can
play at home
alright the words going to be okay it's
going to be Paris something else in [ __ ]
I gotta have something filthy in that
[ __ ] gonna be the last one alright
Paris Kardashians and what else
God what the [ __ ] else is yiy would suck
at and I can certainly couldn't create
the [ __ ] show Paris Kardashian [ __ ]
and itself before [ __ ] pit bulls so get
that one I got you an easy one
alright let's get back to spam stuff
calm everybody buying for an official US
postage using your own computer and
printer print postage for any letter any
package any class of mail then just hand
your mail to the mail carrier
you'll never waste valuable time going
to the post office again so you can
focus on what really matters right bang
is that broadly computer [ __ ] next
you growing your business I mean you
stamps I use stamps coms anytime I'm a
[ __ ] you know selling posters at the
end of my shows you know
send them out go out there I'm I'm dumb
you know if I can figure out how to use
it so can you
right now sign up for stamps comm use my
last name burr for this special offer
for week trial plus $110 bonus offer
including postage and a digital scale
don't wait go to Stan's calm before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
birth at stamps.com enter ber I don't I
thank god that's over
so I'm not I'm not that's not on my
sarong fufu
alright how many minutes we have to here
32 32 what you gonna do she's still not
back with the [ __ ] microphone Nia is
in the closet
good gravy all right we got love we got
letters this week we got somebody from
Poland Oh some [ __ ] musicians going
to tell me there's no guitar on
chameleons of course somebody's just go
oh actually there's not a guitar it's a
[ __ ] xylophone alright whatever
how'd your band do how's your band
alright and she's back well you know I'm
just going to pause so we can stop
torturing people here I love the pause
button oh okay and we're back everybody
alrig wants to get inside a [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is $10,000 pyramid all right Nia
you're up first will be giving or
receiving I will be receiving well what
they say be giving it taken yeah do they
think giving or I don't [ __ ] is
something like that you know you may
given the password I are taking the
[ __ ] clues
alright Gundy ahead if you had to give a
take alright ok ready ready are we on
the clock here yes a detention can we
get a clock in clock time here I'm gonna
get one of these on youtube right now
what no we don't do that all right here
we go use the stopwatch thing on the
computer the people at home the fans at
home got to hear a [ __ ] clock going
alright okay we're back and there's only
33 seconds on this clock so there's four
things you got to get okay
our topic or I'm just just not matter
this is just random [ __ ] that came out
of my head
you got you got 33 seconds let's see how
many you can get okay all right you
ready ready and here we go okay this is
a city it's a one of the great cities in
the world our thing and people love it
they talk down to you they [ __ ] hate
you oh you smell get out of my country
you stupid American Way
you're a stupid American I'm going to do
you like my braids Harris yeah oh my god
sticking in my [ __ ] I'm going to marry a
rapper hey my dad doesn't he has his
dick but he's a woman now Kim Kardashian
uh Kris Jenner
hey we got it I wonder what they're
doing keeping up with the car to get so
you got to you want to keep playing your
clues are horrific shut up Oh like
what's up my swash girl now
what but he still has a dick it's true
I'll show everything I think this up
like SWAT and that was supposed to be a
clue I was thinking she did a porno all
right let's do let's we got two more all
right here we go
you're right thank you you got passage
is this fun all right here we go you
ready okay I mean we be a be taking or
receiving giving a receiving quarters
[ __ ] it is receiving okay here we go
you're saying that all right here we go
starting 22 I
well we're misunderstood I didn't bite
that mailman he looked at me first
pimple yes
all right this is this is something that
you say and people get mad and it can
stick and smell sometimes but if it's a
fresh one it's great and you [ __ ]
stick it you stick it right between your
legs between your legs I know
keep going [ __ ] yes worst name first
name [ __ ] worse now that is bad yeah
whoo you did it you just get in my long
river that would be asked to be
undisputed pyramids no that will never
happen that's the law to be like I come
on
so that's a real show you give your gun
yeah if you took work away from me oh
come on I will never be on a charades
team with you oh come on I will never I
gotta come up with some and and do you
why don't you do it
why aren't you [ __ ] in love with
someone I'll do it how about that all
right didn't you just say that yes no I
want way to come what no I got it well
great I will do it on Thursday okay
we're doing on Thursday all right you
come up with you got we got the quick
little timer there I know stick it up
with a lot actually I probably
disqualified the last one because I use
the word twice when I was trying to get
the Kardashians right Hail Mary around
Hey look what we're doing over here
keep it up with the kardashians it
worked though it did work what do you
want for me all right coming up a bender
here hey it's a rough one you know
all right talking about your birthday
yes I did I had a great time mm-hmm it
was a whole birthday weekend yes it was
it was I had my own boob said alcoholic
one tonight and why were you with Stone
sober and you watched me and Joe DeRosa
just [ __ ] we were having fun you were
having fun yeah
but eventually I had to leave yeah well
you want party so you know what you can
do and then you know last night was
phenomenal also and then I went down to
the improv Ben Bailey was in town the
great Ben Bailey yeah yeah we hung out
we had a couple drinks just [ __ ]
laughs and telling stories and uh DeRosa
was down I was a great time you know
then I got to go to work to myself let
me read these things and uh I'm gonna go
this was fun I'm going to go
have a taco all right I'll see you in a
little bit okay thank you for playing we
have a wonderful addition of our home
game for you I think you got it I think
you actually got the two right in the
end
all right here's somebody else I'm late
to the party with on YouTube but I'm
sure I'm not the only one write a song
I'm not being you I'm not the only one
with mixed emotions you guys seen this
kid that just it's it's [ __ ] a lair I
feel bad because he's got some sort of
issue but like he just he just [ __ ]
goes around and he tells people this
charlie is it selling off he just [ __ ]
goes into gyms and tells people that
he's the greatest and he goes let's spar
and they have no [ __ ] clue you know
he just goes in and he fights an
accountant and the count just kind of
puts his gloves on and this kid swings
for the fences and [ __ ] knocks out an
accountant and turns around and you see
that one punch knock down an accountant
deck innings like that guy was a Marine
he talked all the [ __ ] he actually
started calling up professional fighters
and I was surprised that some of them
actually took time out of their day to
fight the guy and I mean and some of the
most compelling [ __ ] I've ever seen a
granted they have like 74,000 hits two
hundred nineteen thousand hits 100 5,000
hits so once again I'm sure you're just
finding out about it now yes yes I am
have you watched the YouTube video that
it just shows how the [ __ ]
differential works how the [ __ ] did you
miss that oh that's right
because you don't have time to watch all
of it alright so if you get a chance
watch this kid Charlie Zelle enough oh
my god he's got the flip phone and he
just calls this guy keeps calling this
guy a [ __ ] clown I don't know a lot
about like people's like names and [ __ ]
but I will say this about the kid he's
got the [ __ ] balls to go in there man
I wouldn't do that anybody can call up a
professional boxer it talk [ __ ] but to
actually show up for the [ __ ] match I
don't know he fought like he flood [ __ ]
Floyd Mayweather senior
and then he was losing so he stepped out
of the steps out of the [ __ ] ring and
then step back in and tried to sucker
punch the guy and then somebody jumped
in like bare-knuckle beat him down it's
just it's insane anyways you got it you
gotta watch it Charlie Zelan off a spell
spell it for you ze le and Oh ffs I hope
he doesn't get hurt and I hope he
doesn't hurt anybody and but he he talks
[ __ ] like who is that [ __ ] Will Forte
character Calhoun what the [ __ ] is his
first name
Will Forte Calhoun Tim Calhoun um Tim
Calhoun I Tim Calhoun think that we
should sell the Statue of Liberty he
talks [ __ ] like that
he's on the phone go your [ __ ] clown
I'm gonna come down the greatest of all
time conduct me fears your [ __ ] clown
he never raises it up it's like it's
some of the best [ __ ] talk and I've
heard just as far as like you a unique
style so I got to give it up for that
but it's definitely some of the more
bizarre [ __ ] are you going to watch
which of course set me down a rabbit
hole of watching people fight and I saw
the bus driver that throws the uppercut
at that girl who's [ __ ] screaming at
him and I know you're not supposed to
hit a woman but in defense of him he led
with an uppercut and I watched what
happened when Buster Douglas did that so
in a way I thought that that was a
generally move before he grabbed her by
her hair and threw her off the bus
I know the things that I find
entertaining I know I'm out of my mind
all right
Poland everybody I got I got I got a
letter from Poland
hey you freckled-faced [ __ ] why won't
you come to Poland it's beautiful and we
have great alcohol I would love to go
there you know what the [ __ ] I live on
because I live on the other side of the
world and you're the first guy that's
asked me to go there maybe I've had like
maybe three emails I'll go there I'll
stand there in front of five you Charles
Bronson looking [ __ ] I'll stand
over there in front of you know I don't
give a [ __ ] where you got nice beaches
up north and there's a nice town down
south I don't know about Warsaw I know
what's going on there
you guys still have horses in your army
have you [ __ ] updated your [ __ ] you
know you'd still they live next to
Germany you know you got to watch out
for those [ __ ] I was a cheap shot all
right it's beautiful we have alcohol all
right just a question when will you come
to the [ __ ] Saudi or to the [ __ ]
Saudi Arabia or Dubai or Kuwait I don't
know when they like us I'm not going
over there and getting kidnap and
getting my head sawed off on [ __ ]
YouTube aids Bilborough just checking in
on you they welcome you know you'd have
to see that to say something now you
couldn't because they need to worry that
they did something even worse to you I
wait till ready they got through the
jugular oh man I would [ __ ] yeah do a
quick little filly set on a just say
everything that would piss them off
which I would say would I have you know
what I would be I'd be rocking and
crying I'd be I'd be a [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] you just sit there waiting for him
you saw your [ __ ] head off like I
know that doesn't happen in Saudi Arabia
but you know if you steal something in
Saudi Arabia they chop your [ __ ] arm
off you know I don't need that pressure
you know I don't [ __ ] me dead
somebody just could just throw something
stolen in your bag because they stole it
next II know I'm going to chop chop
square alright granted I don't know [ __ ]
about any of these countries all I know
is that we've thrown enough rocks at the
Beehive over there I don't feel like
going over there getting stung
that's it right Dubai yeah I'd love to
go to Dubai where they gotta for they
got slave labor that built the whole
[ __ ] thing and they confiscated their
passports and the number one cause of
death with them is suicide I can't go
there and support that [ __ ] that old
[ __ ] City it looks like like the
Kardashians designed it it's beyond
[ __ ] cheesy we've got the tallest
building in the world Elia Kuwait I got
no problem with that
Saudi Arabia scares me Dubai when you
start paying the people that build the
skyscrapers I'll go there and Kuwait you
know I don't know I mean you guys should
kind of like this right we helped you
out in the early 90s well didn't we I
don't know I have no idea that part of
the world scares me I've connected in
Dubai when I was coming back
Mumbai India but I just hear all these
horrible stories that they promise all
these people in Asia that you're going
to come over there there's all these
jobs you're going to make all this money
and then they come over they confiscate
their passports and they don't let them
[ __ ] leave and they see no way out
and they kill themselves I don't know if
that's true I don't know if it was that
if that was at Walmart I forget all
right hey Billy funk face there's no
guitar in that Herbie Hancock album the
bass player the bass is played by her be
on a synth and Paul Jackson the bassist
plays the guitar line on the higher
register of the bass I never [ __ ]
knew that loved the podcast and stand up
let's jam soon see that I made funny and
then what did you do you taught me
something all right
x-men and sexism hey B is for Bill I
haven't seen the Billboard rose mcgowan
is upset about and I agree with your
assessment on the situation but I think
you mischaracterized the effective
displays of male dominance over women I
mischaracterized it is that a word it's
not that someone sees a picture of a man
choking on a woman and thinks it's okay
and then goes and does it himself
rather it's like a piece of a puzzle
it's just one of these [ __ ] agenda
people again a guy sees a picture of a
man choking out a woman then he sees a
picture of a man yelling at a woman then
he sees a picture of a woman being
backhanded by a man you get the point
you see how they do this you say oh he
just led me across the [ __ ] river to
his side like I'm that [ __ ] stupid no
I don't get your point this is what I
understand a kid [ __ ] sees his
parents okay if the dad beats the [ __ ]
out of his mom his entire [ __ ]
childhood I understand that he'll either
not do it or totally [ __ ] do it I
understand that but this whole [ __ ]
thing that you see images and then you
do [ __ ] okay I watched a [ __ ] racing
car with Red Bull on it all day today
there's no [ __ ] way I will ever drink
it certainly would not put it in with
some vodka ever I have no desire to ever
drink that [ __ ] drink human beings
are way more [ __ ] complex
then the the cartoon version you know I
mean like when when people have
meltdowns and people film it and then
like you know people just oh he did that
then therefore he is that it's just
people are way more complex than that
and you don't just see a picture of this
and then see somebody yelling at this
person and bottled like that's all it
just takes billboards and TV shows and
then all of all of the way that I was
raised goes out the window I can tell
you this sir all right with your little
[ __ ] fisher-price [ __ ] point here
that you're making is when I was a kid
the amount of violent [ __ ] movies I
watched all the Friday the 13th I
watched all the [ __ ] Nightmare on Elm
streets I watched all the Halloween
Halloween three one of the worst [ __ ]
movies ever season of the witch I
watched all of those things I saw
Scarface when I was like whatever [ __ ]
although 15 I saw all of that [ __ ]
okay and I could tell you this I never
went out and killed somebody so explain
that to me I never had a woman I never
did any of that so I just it's I don't
agree with that I don't agree with that
I having said that I agreed with them
saying that you know you could have
picked a better picture you know what I
mean I just look at the pictures like I
don't want to see a woman getting choked
I want to see that you know I look at
that fast-forward to where she breaks
out of the chokehold I'd like to see
that anyways let's continue on with this
you get the point
ah I [ __ ] I can I can stand people all
right after a while the man sees the
overall picture that our culture
condones dominance over women it's a
piece of the larger cultural trend this
is literally paint by numbers like this
is this all the [ __ ] you see on TV this
type of thing happened a lot in old
movies just watch any Humphrey Bogart
movie movies can play a huge part in
reinforcing gender inequality in a
culture
can I ask you a question - a lady
whoever the [ __ ] this is do you ever see
anything else in movies you ever see
anything else in movies do you just see
what the man does to the woman so what
about now all these other movies you
know so then I guess you would then
agree that the latest Mad Max was an
anti man movie because I didn't see a
movie but evidently the Mad Max guy
doesn't do anything and the woman takes
the reins so judging that this is the
way that you view x-men then you must
certainly see that the last Mad Max was
obviously you know whatever is perverse
misogynistic what is that [ __ ] word
for someone who hates men I always
forget it because it's never used it's
never brought up it's just called being
a strong woman that fester hatred of men
misandry I mean if I'm saying right M is
a and D are why do you see it as that I
just don't think people are that simple
I think I really believe that when
someone is a little kid okay if they're
a little kid and they're in your house
and you're their parents I really
believe that whole thing that your words
become their thoughts 100% I don't
believe that people like you're with
your kid every [ __ ] day of your kid's
life up until when I don't know the
first time they go away for the first 10
12 years before they ship them off to
camp or even if you don't do that you
could basically be with them almost
every [ __ ] day of their life for the
first 15 years of their life okay and
you're telling me that movie billboards
and movies and that type of [ __ ] will
undo all of your parenting I can look I
can see some [ __ ] that you'll see a
movie and it makes you want to go out
and [ __ ] you know play cowboys and
Indians like we did you know but I never
really went out and [ __ ] killed
anybody right I don't I I know I don't
agree
that I don't understand that the images
are bad and that type of [ __ ] I
definitely get all of that but the fact
I can't make that leap that then it's
all floating around in my head and next
thing you know I punch my wife in the
face and it's not because I'm a bad guy
and had a bad father it's because I saw
too many movie billboards in scenes in
movies I took this to make to give
movies that level of [ __ ] power I you
know I don't know you want to [ __ ]
make me go get a beer okay I'll go buy a
candy bar but I just don't see myself
you know uppercutting some old lady in
the food line because I saw the wrong
movie [ __ ] billboard I disagree with
you agree to disagree sir or man
all right fiancees parents are evil but
I can't do anything about alright so I'm
getting married this month super excited
to marry the love of my life
congratulations by the whole experience
but the whole experience is going to be
awkward and weird because if parents
don't like me
in fact they hate me Jesus I'll not give
you the whole what does she come from
money and your [ __ ] Billy Joel you
marry an uptown girl huh you're singing
in your garage
let's see I'll not give you the whole
convoluted story but the upshot is that
they're conservative upper-class highly
successful latin-american business types
while I'm an Australian middle class
left the arts graduate I knew they came
from money anyway we've been together
for almost a decade now and even though
I know they've said horrible things
about me behind my back and tried to
talk her into leaving me numerous times
they've always been pleasant to my face
oh that's even worse that said there
were a few years there where they didn't
talk to either of us after we told them
we wouldn't baptize the hypothetical
children we still don't have but we we
don't mention that okay so you guys are
agnostic or something on them basically
it's going to kill me to have to look at
if they're stupid [ __ ] heads on my
wedding day we only invited them out of
a sense of obligation but now it's
hitting home that I'm actually
going to be part of this family now what
I need is a long-term plan of attack to
survive the next few decades until they
shuffle shuffle off this mortal coil
I know living a happy life with their
daughter should all should be all the
revenge I need but if you saw her
father's face you'd want to give him the
old right there Fred to guess I need
some kind of middle ground any advice
Fanta nuts I don't know what that means
go [ __ ] yourself come to Australia
imagine that some sort of red nut over
there I have no idea
Oh Joe bartnik just texted me said
smiling like the butcher's dog good for
him
alright uh any advice the most important
thing you said there is that you're
realizing that you're marrying into this
family and that is something that you
never really [ __ ] think about enough
I don't think enough people do until
yeah yep just picture this person is
going to hold your child some day and
want to take the kid to a ball game you
know or whatever so there is that but uh
I don't know the only way to do it I
would there's one way to you could just
try to kill the guy with kindness or you
could just sit down and look at the guy
and just say look man whose kid no I
know you don't like me I know you just
being polite a lot of you no respect for
your daughter or whatever but you know
you don't have to be nice to me anymore
you know we can see each other on the
holidays or whatever anytime you want to
come over what I don't say that don't
see you no one who coming over ah Jesus
that would drive me nuts if the guy was
being phony nice to me I would at some
point you know have to say to the guy
who listened to you don't maybe just say
that go out golfing with the guy just
say listen man I don't wanna be any more
of a thorn in your side than I already
am just know that you don't have to
pretend to like me okay then you just
[ __ ] walks off the first tee
that's SSS I got to be honest with you
do it I don't know what to tell these
these are tough ones man this is really
[ __ ] how close do you live to them
that's another one you know if you guys
live a state away and you only see them
three four times a year you can tough
out a couple of weekends you know what I
mean
however if you know if they live right
down the [ __ ] Street you know and
then they don't approve of you and then
you have a kid and then they're going to
question how you're bringing it up and
they're already getting involved they're
already I can tell you this they're
already way too [ __ ] involved all
right this is the deal you can say
whatever you [ __ ] you want about whoever
your kids dating until they get married
once they get [ __ ] married you got to
back off you know unless it's obviously
something horrible the person's one
person's abuse and the other person but
like they got to back the [ __ ] off so
maybe you got to have that conversation
just be like listen I know you don't
like me but I love your daughter and she
loves me and we got married so you need
to deal with that yeah [ __ ] him
yeah you need to deal with it we got
married all right so I don't need you
coming over here giving me the [ __ ]
stink face in my own house all right you
already did it once you do it again I'm
going to take your head and stick it
right in the [ __ ] icebox
all right I thought [ __ ] had enough
of you yes [ __ ] this guy I have no good
advice for this for you sir I don't know
what to tell you I just hope it works
out but uh don't take any [ __ ] from the
guy and when it comes to you and your
wife I would just make jokes about it
you know I'd be like hey you know I'm
going to go hang out we get dad today
she like really no he hates me remember
whatever you know just keep it like but
don't joke about it too much because
then she'll say but it really bothers me
they know that I do whatever you like
each other sir um I think you're gonna
be okay but I'm lying to you if I said
if I didn't tell you that 17 percent of
me thinks that you're really [ __ ]
stepping into some [ __ ] here but you
know what everybody gets married does so
good luck see ya good luck to you but
don't take any [ __ ] from that guy
I think you can get to the mom you can
get some Egan charm right right I bet
you can charm and once women are more
forgiving right until they're not and
then they'll [ __ ] kill you in your
sleep but generally speaking the [ __ ]
more forgiving and I think if they she
really sees a love between the two you
she could back up and then that's what
you do yes what you do you divide and
conquer [ __ ] him
alright I think I'm onto something [ __ ]
that guy make make her mom love you
alright
that's it and then she'll start nagging
at him and he'll either go one or two
ways he'll either give in and eventually
like you or two he'll it'll [ __ ] eat
him up and he'll die sooner alright
Jesus had to go all the way to there
bill yeah evidently it did alright last
one here we go
dating an older guy Oh ugh hey Bill I'm
twenty-two year old female from Slovenia
Slovenia modal thank you for the podcast
it makes me laugh out loud which not
many things can do that's [ __ ] great
I would love to go over there at some
point also that Eastern European tour is
going to [ __ ] happen I just have to
have time in my schedule because all of
those countries I've never been to from
[ __ ] Lithuania and [ __ ] Astoria
whatever the [ __ ] that other one is
up there all the way down through
Romania and back up all I know is is if
I can [ __ ] somehow get over and see
all those countries get a bunch of
different stamps on my passport I'm into
that [ __ ] plus they're one of those
places like Prague or something has all
those Art Deco all that art deco
furniture that all the places over here
they order it from for nothing and then
Jack it up over here what I'm going to
buy a desk over there and ship it
[ __ ] around the world like I'm going
to save any money that's a stupid idea
anyways I'm 22 years ago ok I would love
to hear you taking my situation I'm a
university student and I play sports
professionally here in Slovenia keeping
busy working out about 8 times a week my
first coach since I was like 12 years
old is now my really close friend oh my
god his name is and woody is it
he since moved on to coach
internationally I almost said couch
coach internationally but we still keep
in touch he knows me from when I
a little girl and he used to always tell
me I was like his younger sister but I
but recently I noticed he switched his
approach gross
he's a 35 year old single guy my god the
[ __ ] red flags I can barely see the
type here anymore and he only comes to
Slovenia and July through August we were
always able to talk for hours
tell failed attempts at dating to each
other and generally get along better
than I have ever got along with anybody
in my life so far
he's always makes me laugh complements
my personality and how good I look but
never in a creepy or disturbing way okay
alright my experience with guys my age
was never like that I'm not trying to
say I'm too mature for them but I would
always compare them to him and they
would mostly bore me in connection was
never there as much as it is with him
I feel like boys my age are pushovers at
least those I had experiences with I
feel they couldn't offer me in a
relationship more than this older guy
offers me in just a friendship yeah and
also when you're 35 this guy's going to
be 50 so there's also that and then
you're still going to want to go out and
he's going to be ready for nap time so
know that too he's 35 he's almost out of
the league if you're an athlete you know
I mean 35 that's when you guys start
taking a legal drug it drugs you know to
hang around for next to couple seasons
right anyways she says anyways we are
hanging out a lot during this summer and
I feel more and more vibes and attempts
from him he takes me out to eat and
drink he's always asking me somewhere I
know he's putting the moves on me my
issue is that I now I know we are in
different stages of our lives I know he
wants to get married and have children
to [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this
guy you're 22 you got the whole life
ahead of you when the [ __ ] did he start
hitting on you then now this isn't fair
this is like shooting fish in a barrel
you've known him since he was you were
nah-nah-nah stay away from this guy
this is how I know this guy's a creep
because even I wouldn't do this okay
hahaha [ __ ] walk away sir
stand down I most certainly am NOT ready
for anything like that
children all should she's saying I like
to go I like to drink go out my friends
getting compliments from guys all to
soothe my self-esteem which is not fully
developed yet exactly I'm still finding
myself and I know you will interpret
this as I want to [ __ ] around no I don't
but this is not really the case I
actually want to find a right person and
fall in love well you're very mature for
your age actually 22 I'm dodging his
attempts and usually laughed him off
when he puts the moves on me
get away from this guy I don't want to
read this it's making me uncomfortable
yada-yada yada-yada yada-yada I don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] this she
said sorry if that was hard to read my
English is a little rusty English is
tremendous yeah stay away from this guy
alright I came if that was so disturbing
to me that I came he's still currently
your coach
[Music]
anyways I feel more vibes when my way
where the [ __ ] is this thing I got to
find my first coach since I was 12 he
sense move on to coach internationally
but we still keep in touch all right I
don't know when the [ __ ] he moved on but
was he easy no no no no no no yeah [ __ ]
that all right listen this is what you
got to hold on to okay the fact that you
feel the way that you do in your 22
years old there is somebody out there
your age that is like you and if it was
easy to go out and find love everybody
would find it alright but the problem is
is you know you got it you got to go
through a bunch of mistakes first all
right so I don't know you I don't know
him but this is not the person you gotta
settle down don't don't [ __ ] do this
don't do it alright he's got way way too
much of a mental advantage on you at 35
and 22 when he could really [ __ ] hurt
ya
I say you deal with the fact that you
find guys your aids are not mature and
you're going to run to somebody with you
sound like you're really good-looking
you're into sports right you're getting
these compliments when you go out so you
probably have like these [ __ ]
Yolo douches hitting on you which you
need you know what you need you need a
nerd I think you need a nerd go find
some [ __ ] kid that likes to read you
know he probably has an idea to build an
app whatever these [ __ ] kids are
doing that's what you want to do you
know when I go [ __ ] around with your 35
year old creepy y'all want to get
married to have kids I'll do you do yeah
that's why you're hitting on a 22 year
old you piece of [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] that guy all right I would yeah
stick with people your own roughly your
own age all right that's coming from an
older creep like me so you know it's
good advice all right that's the podcast
for this week I hope you guys enjoyed it
and congratulations to Pittsburgh
Penguins fans and you know what also to
San Jose shark fan to know I've been
there
plenty of times seeing the Bruins losing
finals to all those great Edmonton teams
so my condolences but hey you actually
got to the finals and you got a great
team to build on and that's it one down
one to go
the NBA ends and I guess I'll start
watching a little bit of baseball but
I'm I think I'm going to stick with the
Formula One racing until I get the
football season we'll see what's up all
right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves and
I'll check at audio on Thursday